hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival now you may be going Highway
mark you're too pro you beat this game
and I'm like well I am great and
magnificent but there is more to this
mystery than meets the eye
there is a hardcore difficulty right
here that I I'm going to find this is
gonna be a completionist playthrough so
if you're looking for the secret hints
failed pause attempts what does that
even mean
I don't even know what failed pause
attempts means but there are I found how
many did I find I believe I found 19 of
26 items yeah 19 I found 19 items I am
going to try very hard to find every of
the items and then I'm gonna try to beat
the game on hardcore mode which might be
bad because I have yet to beat slender
the eight pages the original one so I
don't see how I could do any better if
it's even more difficult than it was
thank you hello text yah
but this also means that I need to
explore a bit more once I get in here
and really take in the environment my
sorrows that might have been a little
too much there but anyway you get the
general idea I spit everywhere like
literally there's spit all over my
screen right now okay so I'm on the
lookout for any other landmarks that
might be important for me to visit like
this brick wall mmm very milky it's
nothing alright let's not waste any time
I've already picked up pretty much all
of the notes in the first area I just
need to make sure that I check every
room of the house because I feel as
though there might have been one page in
there between this and
the mining entrance part of the game
that I could definitely see again now
the reason that I'm doing is this is
because people said that there was more
stuff if you beat the game on hardcore
much like I probably at some point will
do a repeat on hardcore of them of the
game grey which is made by some of the
same people that made cry of fear and
has a totally different ending if you
played on the hardest difficulty so
that's just another one of these games
and I'll be revisiting at some point
down the road I mean I know I need to
catch back up on some of these things
I've been getting so caught up on all
the individual games that I often
neglect series and I should probably get
back into it so at some point down the
road you can expect that but for now I'm
still walking on this long and winding
road to the house and here it is
was there anything else that I might
have missed yes
no I gotta imagine that there's summer
to Easter Egg if my voice doesn't crack
too much I mean there's bound to be
something along the lines of a hidden
watch um of dues its that the Creator
the game probably felt like he was
interested in putting in the game I
don't know I don't know what i'm talking
about but mmm these trees okay there's
another path up here wait a minute
there's just this empty part here and is
this another path or oh I guess I could
have taken a shortcut from never mind
alright I wasted some time I thought I
was being led on to something new but
apparently I'm just an [ __ ] I don't
have a flashlight but it's getting dark
and I am scared of the dark
but I look a lovely abandoned house hmm
this looks good for sale oh that's a
good sign I think I'll give it a try I
mean there's bound to be like the only
Easter Egg I found was the slide
achievement so
there's bound to be other stuff besides
that hello maybe I could play on the
swings maybe just maybe I can't even see
the swings ah there's some history okay
so that definitely says that this person
knows Kate and that means the character
that I'm playing is most likely Lauren
Laura okay all right good
all right you don't scare me you do
she's got to make sure all the windows
are closed okay found that phone line
appears to be dead where's the
flashlight I know there's a flashlight
in there ah there it is thank you all
right now that I could boom boom boom
boom now I'm definitely looking for just
about everything I can find like the
house and in life I mean there's bound
to be a lot of stuff in the house anyway
just considering its the house
nothing like those rocket oldies
anything in here nope okay we're good
all right you can shut up god you're
loud okay so the downstairs is just
about all searched nothing new here I
don't imagine that I missed anything in
the house but I have to be thorough
because I do want to get as close to a
completionist playthrough as possible
which may or may not be possible all my
primary objectives is not to actually
get everything cuz I don't know if I can
or if I'll just so happen to miss
something my primary objective is
definitely to beat the game which is
gonna be a challenge just I'm going to
find out slender's going to find me and
murder me with his long tentacles of
death doom and I did find out the piece
these little statue s are from blue Isle
Studios out there it is yeah that that
thing this is the blue Isle room alright
um I could have sworn there were three
things oh come on I didn't find the key
I thought the key was on the bed but I
didn't see it well this is not a good
start because I've already been through
the whole house and I've somehow missed
a key which means and I'm an idiot and
an [ __ ] hooray hooray for ineptitude
sorry for using such a big word
everybody ineptitude means platter
obelisk that's what that means
no all right shut up out there to shop
where's the damn key um well welcome to
10 hours of Mark flailing like an idiot
as he tries to find a simple key in the
house Wow Wow well the flashlight was in
the same place why can't the damn keys
be in the same place they were on the
bed before but now they is not and I am
lay bond Ironman I've been here I've
been all of the here I've been every of
here looking for a key
I specifically walked through this house
looking for things and I cannot find
things well ain't this just a big pile
of douche big pile of douchiness maybe
because it's hardcore
the key is so like hard to find it's
just like really hard
mmm okay I got it okay I'm good ah fahh
site okay thank you
what the hell flashlight what are you
doing to come back I think I think my
flashlight just died that does not bode
well for me haha my bad how am I gonna
search his rooms at the ding dong
flashlight oh there's the keys good
found key can't see there must have been
a door that I didn't open before and um
yeah wow it's really dark now that's
great okay now we can finally move on
but I still can't see anything
hahaha
to the woods her ah I'm not I'm not
anymore happy by than you're alright
there's supposed to be another key in
here but it's so bleedin dark I can't
see anything I screwed I don't even need
to unlock the back door can just go
around screw it
I'm out of here I'm not being in that
dark house any longer than I need to let
go
ba ba ah na is this oh good I thought it
was I can't tell cuz it's so dark
alright get ready for one horrifically
bad attempt at slender the eight pages
here we go run fast like bunny was it ah
oh that's some uh huh that's some else
alright doing good found other notices
of note worthiness I can't believe I
literally wandered through that house
for so long that my flashlight went out
I don't think that's supposed to happen
oh I am such an a-hole I am such an a
word all right come on be in easy spots
being easy spots now my favorite toy
growing up as a kid
easy spots was great didn't everybody
remember easy spots god I love that game
yeah you weren't a 90s kid unless you
played easy spots and it's nowhere to be
found
it's in bad spots bad spots was the game
that kids got for Christmas when they
had parents that didn't care about him
ah come on it's not in here
you gotta be kidding me okay
what whatever
whatever man
whatever man I mean I don't even need
your pages man I can do this all on my
own
ha I forgot that I'm not on my own I am
with Slendy man go away like I've said
before you're a little fancy you're a
little 105 pound pass e oh what's that
you couldn't even lift a car but I can I
definitely can cuz I'm too bro
wait a minute I'm not been here before
it is the first page I got hey back off
I need to strategically use e the sprint
boost that I get from looking at you huh
the mysterious Porta Potty you're making
some drawings while you were on the John
a Slendy in that pathetic ah why is it
written in brown ah okay alright I
officially I can check that off of my
list of jokes to make I made a a poop
joke alright just need a fart joke and a
penis joke yeah mama come here Dukey
gosh ah
haha
noise lynnie hey why you gotta be a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you then I didn't want
your page anyway cuz you're a dick
hooch you're you suck you suck buddy
that's what you do
you suck what kind of a ol just stands
up there and guards his babes
what kind of what kind you did did you
hear me what kind of [ __ ] stands
there and guards a page whatever I'm
getting it no I don't even care
back off [ __ ] I am too pro oh oh good I
thought there wasn't even a page up here
I for fellow go to hell and die fire by
fire in fire jump in fire then die
ah ah back out there buddy
like I've said to all of my illustrious
and beautiful handsome Franz Franz I
call them fans cuz your fans and my
friend yeah me and my friends that's
we're gonna be from now and the
markiplier friends I'm actually totally
turned around here I have no idea about
the layout of this place did this have
roofs before where is he I don't assume
I don't think there's had a roof what is
this this doesn't look familiar at all
what Oh what is this where is he okay
you keep shaking my video but I do not
see him where is he you kidding me oh
don't be a [ __ ] and here's the park
sign but there's a high we are
flip flip hi back off crime my personal
space bread I need to get the thing from
the trailer park here cuz it's a park
ooh ah don't do that stop making my
Carol one click
you can't pour it into a container
that's not fair
I'm dead I'm i ah ah there's no page or
something I don't know there probably is
a page but I can't even tell anymore
my flashlight probably gonna go out soon
plenty such an a-hole he's in a whole
giant hole of a where am I now I don't
even know right back complete oh here
I'm at a car please have a page H on the
side maybe Naz right the first time
watch your eyes you don't have a page oh
I'm so dead it is now exceptionally dark
come on come on flash lucky come on
flash light last a little bit just a
little longer hold out for me buddy
now hold on that's a dead end hold out
you can make it I like a page ah I think
you're looking on the up-and-up only
need two more before Slendy Diggs is I'm
looking at right I'm hi wow you're
really tall man you're like taller than
you were before bro oh my flashlights
God my god
I got that by the moon navigate by moon
never bad about after you read done
where's that what is this
I fell into a quarry I fell into the
quarry their page of the quarry I
wouldn't even know cuz I can't seem to
be in front of my face where is he
hide right now a thing is right there
I'm not sure I didn't see the news
camera have a night vision
well I was pretty pathetic okay get
ready for 10 episodes of me trying to
beat this one part oh yeah oh no oh no
okay all right okay all right maybe I
should just skip ahead to the end of the
game in hardcore mode and that would
count maybe I don't know all right so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching if this is a fruitless endeavor
and there actually isn't anything at the
end let me know now so I don't waste my
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation or do you
sit I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
Oh
but
go